salut à tous bienvenue dans ce nouvel
opus dans quête d'europe on est
actuellement à emmaüs défi l'atelier du
19e arrondissement de paris
dans cette émission je vous emmène au
portugal depuis quelques mois le pays
renoue avec la croissance mais pauvreté
et chômage sont toujours le quotidien
des portugais nous ferons elle est
ensuite aux pays bas amsterdam a imaginé
un dispositif quelque peu insolite pour
réinsérer ces sans abri enfin terminus
sur l'île de gau large de l'ecosse là
bas les îliens ont mis en place une
véritable transition énergétique mais
d'abord direction l'italie depuis
l'accession au pouvoir de matteo renzi
premier ministre les promesses pleuvent
au risque de décevoir les italiens c'est
yael goujon qui nous en parle
yaël pourquoi vous êtes vous intéressé à
la personnalité de matteo renzi alors
météo rézilta river il ya maintenant un
an et demi presque au pouvoir en italie
avec dans sa charrette plein de grands
discours qui voulait réformer l'italie
après vingt ans de berlusconisme et
s'est demandé comment ça allait devenir
sur le terrain une application concrète
de d'une politique volontariste donc
vous avez été à la rencontre des acteurs
de ces réformes à rome
avant l'été n'est pas encore finie mais
la rentrée politique elle est bien
entamée depuis son arrivée au pouvoir
renzi bouleverse la péninsule l'une de
ses réformes phares c'est celle du sénat
je réfléchisse à ce matin en fait que je
n'ai pas l'âge pour siéger au sénat et
que je serai le dernier président du
conseil à vous demander le vote de
confiance
le projet de rennes dit que la chambre
haute comporte 100 sénateurs contre 315
aujourd'hui ils ne seront plus rémunéré
ce qui représenterait une économie de
500 millions d'euros pour l'état après
de longues années à la rai le
journaliste vedette mineo est devenu
sénateur l'année dernière si son génie a
voulu que le sénat se suicident en
transformant une assemblée de loin de
grandes orientations
même avec des compétences politiques
limité pour n'en faire qu'une assemblée
de conseillers locaux politiques et ces
drames à celle en faisant ça on détruit
un pont de la constitution et ont
produit un système autoritaire comme une
cinquantaine de parlementaires du parti
démocrate de renzi le nouveau sénateur
fait partie des frondeurs de l'ailé
gauche
chaque interview est l'occasion de
constater cet affrontement notamment sur
la réforme du travail
il manquerait la maladie mentale en
restant poli abandon en fait le marché
du travail est devenu fou avec un nombre
hallucinant de précaires au moment même
où les riches continuent de s'enrichir
et les mafias de s'engraisser parce que
nous avons eu 20 ans de libéralisme et
de mirage berlusconien appuyé par une
gauche soumises qui abandonnait toute
lutte sociale pour une idée on gagnera
les élections et ensuite on gouvernera
la ministre mahdia en charge de la
simplification de la fonction publique
vient deux à trois fois par semaine au
sénat pour défendre ses réformes
l'occasion aussi pour les journalistes
de savoir où en sont les économies
prenez pour les ministères au fait
concernant les voitures de fonction où
en est-on pas plus de cinq voitures par
ministère c'est bien ça oui oui le
décret d'application est imminent et
désormais on ira tous à pied aux
réunions
lle relance et rigueur politique de
l'offre et de la demande d'essai en même
temps la fiscalité et les dépenses
publiques une logique économique qui
séduit aussi les entrepreneurs
les pme constituent l'essentiel du tissu
industriel italien en banlieue de rome
virgilio pallini dirige une entreprise
d'une centaine de salariés fondée il ya
140 ans par son arrière grand père en
italie a besoin des ces réformes dont on
parle depuis 20 ans l'entreprise sont
trop taxés en italie et du coup elles
n'investissent pas rester si je veut
licencier un salarié qui travaille mal
pour le remplacer par un meilleur
actuellement la procédure est
extrêmement longue mais tous les
italiens ne s'enthousiasment pas autant
pour celui qu'on surnomme des
démolisseurs pour moi lundi c'est un
berlusconi jeunes et ils ne pratiquent
pas les bunga bunga
mais sa politique est identique il se
dit de gauche mais son action le
contredit il va supprimer un morceau du
droit du travail
ce que berlusconi n'a pas réussi à faire
en 20 ans alors si c'est ça une
politique de gauche
malgré les réformes le taux de chômage
continue de stagner et l'embellie tarde
à venir
du coup la grande s'organise
une signature pour le référendum contre
le pacte budgétaire européen campo dei
fiori le collectif stop à l'austérité
recueille les signatures nécessaires
pour organiser un référendum
d'initiative populaire comme la loi
italienne autorise l'austérité en elle
même ne fonctionne pas il ya des
recettes économiques assez simple qu'on
pourrait appliquer mais ça c'est au
gouvernement actuel de le faire
la règle d'or budgétaire ici comme
ailleurs en europe est pointé du doigt
ce référendum permettrait à l'italie de
s'extirper de ce carcan car à l'heure où
renzi promet près de 100 milliards
d'euros pour relancer l'économie
ses marges de manoeuvre sont réduites
yaël on en est où de toutes ces réformes
aujourd'hui alors certaines ont déjà été
faites comme la réforme du travail dont
on a entendu parler un petit peu dans le
reportage le job act ils l'ont appelé on
aura une flexibilité ou une précarité en
fonction du vocabulaire qu'on veut
utiliser du code du travail et des
contrats de travail qui sont ou ont été
simplifiées par ailleurs il ya eu la
réforme du sénat
ça c'est bien moins avancé puisqu'il
reste au moins trois lectures encore
entre le sénat et l'assemblée est
probablement une un référendum ou alors
un passage en force et on retrouve ce
passage en force en fait de plus en plus
dans renzi qui s'impatientent de voir
les les réformes italienne avancer à
petits pas et là il ya quelques semaines
pendant quelques semaines en tout cas il
ya eu des des manifestations importantes
sur la réforme de l'école et c'est
quelque chose qui est sur lequel il
menace de passer en force
du coup faisant en faisant voter le vote
de confiance du gouvernement près les
parlements et on voit aussi que sur la
question de l'union civile pour les
couples homosexuels il ya aussi une
grande résistance de la part des
italiens qui ont défilé par dizaines de
milliers centaines de milliers dans les
rues de rome ces dernières semaines mais
qu'en est il des italiens aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'ils sont déçus
alors il ya une forme de ambivalence
disons que les italiens sont assez
contents de devoir enfin un homme
politique qui montre un certain
volontarisme
par ailleurs ils commencent à se lasser
parce que
la reprise économique est extrêmement
timide le chômage continue d'augmenter
on a des 42 % de chômage chez les jeunes
de 15 à 24 ans qui est énorme
on a une croissance qu'on peut à peine
appelé comme ça puisqu'elle fait 0 3%
donc c'est une stagnation en fait après
des mois et des mois de récession
les italiens commencent sérieusement à
se lasser de voir cette situation
économique qui ne change absolument pas
et on le retrouve dans les urnes en mai
il ya eu des élections la moitié des
italiens se sont abstenus le mouvement 5
étoiles continuent de séduire il est pas
loin de 20 % et l'extrême droite devient
la première force d'opposition ligue du
nord qui prend le leadership à droite en
parlant justement des questions
économiques et en faisant valoir aussi
les problèmes migratoires que matteo
renzi essaye de faire valoir au niveau
européen merci beaucoup yaël merci laura
si un pays a réussi à retrouver le
chemin de la croissance c'est à dire le
portugal pourtant pour les portugais la
réalité est tout autre c'est sandra
cerqueira qui nous en parle
sandra ce qu'on peut véritablement
parler de reprise au portugal oui sur le
papier tout semble aller mieux on a les
principaux indicateurs économiques qui
sont au beau fixe une reprise des
exportations des investissements
bref le portugal est revenu sur les
marchés donc une reprise mais une
reprise quand même en demi teinte car il
ya encore une dette publique très
importante et un taux de chômage élevé
le coup de l'austérité continue à être à
être très important au portugal comme on
le voit dans le dans le reportage
donc on vous suit dans la banlieue de
lisbonne où vous vous êtes rendu avec
mounir souci
ça se passe bien
oui ça va être une expérience
intéressante on accueille aujourd'hui
les nouvelles personnes qui sont en ce
moment en train d'être formés et demain
8 nouveaux salariés nous rejoindront
nous sommes dans une bonne dynamique
tottenham écoles en six mois
cette entreprise spécialisée dans les
nouvelles technologies a doublé ses
effectifs
parmi eux lucas au chômage depuis la fin
de ses études son poste n'a rien à voir
avec sa formation mais il n'avait pas le
choix je n'avais pas du tout anticipé
les difficultés qui m'attendait ça a été
un choc de devoir renoncer à mon diplôme
en sociologie pour me réorienter dans un
domaine qui m'était totalement inconnu
celui des nouvelles technologies du web
on dit que c'est une filière d'avenir et
j'ai besoin de travailler
alors j'ai bien dû me rendre à
l'évidence la plupart des personnes
embauchées ici sont des chômeurs de
longue durée
le gouvernement portugais a fait de
cette catégorie une priorité il a mis en
place des aides pour faciliter leur
recrutement
sans elle l'entreprise n'aurait jamais
pu embaucher si vite
les entreprises profitent actuellement
davantage fiscaux presque cinq fois
supérieur quand elles embauchent des
contrats de longue durée
nous avons besoin de beaucoup de monde
cela nous aide à rester compétitifs sur
le marché international d'avoir le code
du travail portugais a profondément été
réformé il est plus facile d'embaucher
plus facile de licencier aussi cela
coûte moins cher aux entreprises grâce à
cette flexibilité dont nous bénéficions
depuis trois quatre ans nous pouvons
nous adapter à l'évolution du volume
d'activité qui varie en fonction du
nombre de projets ainsi nous restons
réactif et nous pouvons répondre aux
besoins réels de nos clients à chaque
mois de septembre
au portugal le taux de chômage a
commencé à baisser il y a deux ans il
est passé de 17,5 à 14%
car la reprise est là la commission
européenne prévoit une croissance de 1,6
pour cent cette année
c'est mieux que la moyenne de la zone
euro
l'économie portugaise est sortie de la
récession les exportations se portent
mieux
mais la reprise reste quand même fragile
et le taux de chômage aurait tendance à
remonter désormais avec une plus grande
flexibilité
beaucoup d'entreprises qui sont sur des
marchés qui ont des croissances rapide
prennent plus de risques et embauchent
plus mais elles licencient aussi plus
facilement
donc cela ne fait pas baisser le chômage
de façon durable
un manque de perspective qui pousse
certains à quitter le pays
catharines a enchaîné les contrats
courts pendant des années elle est
infirmière et n'a jamais pu trouver de
travail durable
le séquençage du collège qu'ils disent
quand on nous propose des contrats de 15
jours d'un mois payés parfois trois ou
quatre euros de l'heure comment vivre
avec ça on ne vit pas on survit
tout augmente le pouvoir d'achat est
toujours plus faible on s'en sort pas il
n'y a que les politiques pour dire que
ça va mieux quand ils disent que
l'austérité derrière nous c'est
complètement faux cette mère de famille
de 40 ans assure que rien n'a changé
pour elle depuis le départ de la troïka
sans espoir elle a décidé de quitter le
pays pour l'angleterre
on a de plus en plus de pères et de
mères de famille de 40 50 ans qui
émigrent pas seulement des jeunes
diplômés loin de là à l'étranger au
moins on trouve du travail correspondant
à un haut niveau d'études et on est payé
à notre juste valeur
il n'y a qu'en qu'il tente pays
malheureusement qu'on peut avoir des
opportunités d'évolution
quarante pour cent de la population
active se dit aujourd'hui prête à
quitter le portugal
le deuxième pays d'europe dont la
population émigrée le plus sandra on
voit clairement dans votre reportage que
finalement c'est une reprise en demi
teinte pour la population portugaise ou
et une reprise en demi teinte car le
coût humain de l'austérité est
considérable les portugais quand ils se
serraient de se serrer la ceinture de
faire des sacrifices et ils le disent il
ya une reprise mais qui ne nous
bénéficie pas à nous donc oui ils sont
sortis de la récession
ils sont sortis d'un plan de rigueur qui
quand même a considérablement baissé les
salaires réduit les prestations sociales
résultat aujourd'hui un portugais sur
cinq vit sous le seuil de pauvreté avec
411 euros par mois donc c'est une
situation complexe qui aujourd'hui un
site beaucoup de personnes à quitter le
pays bah justement combien sont ils à
avoir quitté le portugal depuis la
récession
alors aujourd'hui il ya deux millions
d'émigrés portugais beaucoup de jeunes
notamment il ya 20 % des jeunes diplômés
qui ont quitté le pays infirmiers
professeurs ingénieurs
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya une fuite des
cerveaux aujourd'hui au portugal qui
vide le pays de ses forces vives
sachant aussi que le taux de natalité
est très bas que le pays connaît aussi
une population vieillissante et que le
taux d'illettrisme est important enfin
on a un taux de décrochage scolaire des
plus importants en europe
donc c'est une situation qui va faire
que le pays a des défis considérables à
gérer dans les 20 à 30 prochaines années
donc là le portugal commencent à se
saisir de cette question vous en
essayant de faire revenir les expatriés
il propose des mesures incitatives ya
des fonds européens pour aider al
embauche à la création d'entreprise donc
reste à savoir si tout cela va suffire à
faire revenir la jeunesse pas si sûr
merci sandra merci n'aura pour y insérer
les sans abri les pays bas ont inventé
une solution quelque peu insolite contre
quelques travaux d'intérêt général
il offre canettes de bières et quelques
dizaines d'euros des explications de
flora sauvage le reste que les pays bas
comptent beaucoup de sdf
alors non les pays bas ne compte pas
beaucoup de sdf en fait pendant
longtemps les pays bas ont fait figure
de modèle en la matière pour plusieurs
raisons d'une part ils ont un système
d'aidé sociale assez généreux d'autre
part la gestion se fait au niveau des
vilains des communes chacun gère la
problématique des sans-abri
mais ce modèle commence à se craqueler
on a vu qu au cours des quatre dernières
années le nombre de sdf a augmenté de 10
% aux pays-bas et sont principalement
visés les jeunes et les seniors
donc on vous suit à amsterdam fred vient
tous les jours dans ce local à l'abri
des regards
c'est l'un des vins fdf qui participent
à un projet un peu particulier depuis
deux ans une association financée par
des fonds publics offrent bière
cigarettes repas chauds et petits
salaires à ces sans abri en échange ils
sont chargés de nettoyer le parc dans
lequel il avait l'habitude de passer
leur journée
j'ai commencé à boire en 1979 j'ai
arrêté les drogues dures et je suis
passé à l'alcool c'était bière genièvre
et whisky à volonté dates du losc fred
n'a pas été épargné par la vie j'ai
perdu les trois femmes que j'ai aimé la
première s'est suicidé la deuxième est
morte d'un cancer de l'estomac est la
troisième d'une hémorragie cérébrale
l'objectif est de remettre ces sdf sur
les rails aux pays bas on ne
s'embarrasse pas de questions
philosophiques et plutôt qu'interdire on
préfère encadrer les 100 à 2 afin de
mieux les canaliser ça c'est le registre
où je note ce que chacun consomme
c'est moi qui distribue les guerres
aussi étrange que cela puisse paraître
on travaille aussi sur le problème de
l'alcoolisme
s'il travaille il reçoit 24 euros et
cinq cannettes de bière répartis dans la
journée mais s'ils veulent arrêter on
les aide à se désintoxiquer
au lieu de leur offrir de la bière on
leur donne une prime de 10 euros en bons
d'achat au bout de quatre jours
d'abstinence au départ fred venait pour
la bière mais depuis un mois et demi il
n'a pas touché une goutte d'alcool
j'étais tous les jours dans le parc et
je buvais bien après bière maintenant
j'ai décidé d'arrêter l'alcool mais il
suffit d'une goutte pour que je rechute
on nettoyons le parc on sait qu'on fait
quelque chose pour la société en
attendant de se remettre sur les rails
comme ça on traîne pas dans la rue et on
se sent utile
pour la mairie de secteur ce projet est
une opportunité
cela a permis de vider le parc de ces
sdf un autre clip aux voyous ce qu'il y
à beaucoup de gens qui ont envie de
profiter du parc de la verdure
mais si une grande partie du parc est
occupé par des sdf qui boivent de la
bière toute la journée
c'est gênant pour les riverains car ils
font du bruit ils laissent leurs
canettes traîner maintenant viennent
nettoyer le parc c'est un très bon
projet à mes yeux dans les rues
d'amsterdam
il y a peu de sdf ici la mendicité est
interdite par arrêté préfectoral
aux pays-bas la question des sans abri
est centralisée au niveau des communes
des crédits spécifiques qui sont gérés
et coordonner de manière très efficace
l'objectif est de travailler en amont
pour que personne ne deviennent sans
abri au sein du restaurant de la mairie
d'amsterdam
on emploie des mères célibataires en
difficulté qu'est ce que vous apprenez
ici qu'est ce que ça vous apporte
j'apprends à communiquer à servir les
clients
j'apprends aussi sur moi même
claudia à 24 ans elle a un fils de 2 ans
dans cette société si qu'une fée lien tu
n'avances pas omis de faire par contre
si tu travailles alors tu te construis
une expérience d'au malgré les moyens
mis en oeuvre certains passent à travers
les mailles du filet ce foyer flambant
neuf
accueil des sans abri dans cinquante et
une chambre cela coûte 5 euros la nuit
certains vivent depuis des années dans
la rue ils viennent ici pour dix nuits
pour récupérer un peu il y à d'autres
personnes qui sont sans abri juste pour
quelques mois et qui cherche un endroit
où dormir à 60 ans anna a pas mal
bourlingué
elle était sans domicile fixe en france
avant de revenir à amsterdam sa ville
natale
c'est temporaire mais 16 c sera facile
quand même il ya beaucoup de structures
ici en france je ne sais pas mais je
vois beaucoup plus de gens
je pense que la politique la politique
ici à amsterdam
c'est de rendre le plus le plus possible
invisible le fait que les adss car
aujourd'hui dans les rues d'amsterdam
les sans abri sont devenus invisibles
l'attitude des néerlandais à l'égard des
sdf semble avant tout dictés par le
pragmatisme
ici nous préfèrent organiser le
phénomène au grand jour plutôt que
laisser les gens dormir dehors
flore on voit que ce dispositif quelque
peu innovant a l'air de fonctionner
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne généralise pas
ce type d'action c'est compliqué
généralisée parce que les mentalités
sont différentes
aux pays bas on n'hésite pas à innover à
tenter des choses en france donner
gratuitement des bières à des sans-abri
qui sont pour certains alcoolique ça
peut poser beaucoup plus de questions
que qu'aux pays bas où finalement c'est
plutôt admis ce qui est certain c'est
que les pays bas ont recentré en fait la
gestion des sdf au niveau des communes
qu'en france n'a peut-être trop de
structures et on n'a pas cette idée d'un
guichet unique où le sdf peut se
présenter et être aidés à différents
niveaux
résultat en france les chiffres parlent
d'eux mêmes selon l'insee il ya 112
milles sdf en france moi je suis va
prendre avec des pincettes parce que
c'est toujours difficile à évaluer
+44 % en 11 ans donc
c'est sûr qu'on peut parler d'échec en
france et quand on compare avec les pays
bas ont dit que peut-être quelques idées
à aller chercher là bas mais est ce
qu'il existe une politique au niveau
européen sur ces questions d'exclusion
alors il y a le fonds social européen
mais
la prise en charge de la grande
exclusion se fait encore au niveau des
états chaque état gère à sa façon donc
il ya certainement des idées à prendre
des échanges de bonnes pratiques au
niveau européen qui pourrait se faire
afin de lutter contre la grande
exclusion qui touche tous les états
membres
oui et on le voit notamment depuis le
début de la crise au niveau européen
c'est les chiffres sont affolants merci
beaucoup florian la petite île des gains
au large de l'ecosse compte une centaine
d'habitants mais à eux seuls ils ont
réussi à mettre en place une véritable
transition énergétique
après un périple de 30 heures samia de
chira été à la rencontre de ces petits
aventuriers du bout de l'europe
samia qu'est ce qui vous a marqué à la
rencontre des habitants bildung ce qui
nous a marqué c'est que c'est des gens
qui n'ont pas eu besoin d'attendre que
les dirigeants mondiaux se mettent
d'accord pour faire leur propre
transition énergétique ce qui nous a
marqué aussi c'est le voyage qui est un
peu compliquée et que quelques ferries
par semaine qui peuvent être bloqués ou
annulés en fonction de la météo
mais malgré ce voyage un peu compliqué
c'est une île qui vaut vraiment le
détour parce que vous allez voir c'est
une aventure humaine qui est étonnante
c'est à bord du ferry qui relie la côte
ouest de l'écossé au petit il que l'on
parvient à aig un petit bout de terre
isolée de 30 kilomètres carrés devenue
emblématique car il a été racheté par
ses 90 habitants qui en ont fait une île
presque autosuffisante en énergie
renouvelable
ce matin c'est maggie fife qui assure la
vente des cartes d'électricité elle est
l'une des figures de l'île d'aig 10.50
voilà ta monnaie c'est parfait quand
elle s'est installée ici le système
foncier écossais étaient encore féodal
avant lille appartenaient à des
propriétaires successifs qui ne vivait
pas et qui n'assurait pas habitants la
sécurité du logement
c'est devenu un vrai problème pour les
gens d'ici il finissait par partir donc
on a décidé collectivement qu'on voulait
avoir plus d'influencé sur la façon dont
il était géré les îliens se lance alors
dans un pari un peu fou racheter leur
île grâce à un appel aux dons il récolte
un million et demi de livres en 1997 le
rachat est finalisée mais toute
l'énergie de l'île est fournie par des
groupes électrogènes
commence alors un nouveau défi
l'électrification sega relier lille au
réseau électrique national par un câble
aurait coûté des millions de livres et
aucune compagnie d'électricité n'aurait
fait ça pour si peu d'habitants ça
n'aurait pas été rentable
avec seulement 40 foyers
les îliens décide alors de faire avec ce
qu'ils ont du vent du soleil mais
surtout beaucoup d'eau nous allons sur
la principale turbines hydroélectriques
qui est au nord de l'île à côté de la
sphère de l'aig
john est l'un des architectes du réseau
électrique de l'île s'il tient nous
montrer cette turbine alimenté par un
barrage
c'est quelle est la pièce maîtresse du
système ont produit notre courant grâce
à trois sources d'énergie renouvelables
l'hydroélectrique le photovoltaïque et
l'éolien
on transforme cette énergie grâce à un
système qui fournit l'électricité à
chaque foyer
avec ça on arrive à produire au moins
90% de l'électricité qui est consommée
sur l'île à mais l'énergie renouvelable
ne peut pas être produite on continue il
faut dont la stockée dans des batteries
chaque jour et 10 et ses collègues
mesurent leur niveau de chargement
ça devrait plutôt bon pour
l'hydroélectrique aujourd'hui non
si l'énergie renouvelable vient à
manquer c'est un groupe électrogène qui
prend le relais si le niveau d'énergie
est trop bas on peut prévenir la
population de deux manières soit grâce
aux fous qui est sur la jetée à côté du
magasin où tout le monde va faire ses
courses ou alors on envoie un email aux
habitants pour leur demander de faire
attention à leur consommation
le système repose donc sur la
responsabilité des habitants marie tient
un bed and breakfast grâce à des
subventions elle s'est équipé en
appareils peu gourmands en énergie je
continue quand même à faire très
attention
par exemple je ne met pas en marche trop
d'appareils qui consomment beaucoup
d'électricité en même temps
aujourd'hui un kilowatt revient à 20
pence soit deux fois plus que sur le
continent
mais c'est aussi deux fois moins cher
que lorsque marie utiliser un groupe
électrogène
c'est beaucoup moins contraignant parce
qu'on n'a plus à s'occuper du diesel
pour le groupe électrogène le faire
venir de malek le transférer d'un bateau
dans des bidons tout le temps allumer et
éteindre le groupe électrogène donc ça
nous a vraiment rendu la vie est plus
facile
l'électrification de lille a changé le
quotidien de ses habitants
mais le système a coûté cher plus d'un
million et demi de livres financé pour
moitié par l'union européenne à l'époque
ces hyènes river qui s'est chargé de
récolter les fonds météo bon endroit et
au bon moment pour construire ce système
le financement européen qu'on avait
reçue venait d'un d'un programme du
fonds régional de développement européen
quelle s achever il restait plus de 760
milles pensait dépenser donc on a pu
bénéficier de toute la somme on a eu
beaucoup de chance
si ça avait été un an plus tôt un an
plus tard on aurait eu beaucoup plus de
mal
trouver l'argent dans un archipel où
aucune il n'est relié au réseau
électrique national
elle a été pionnière mais si l'utopie
d'une autosuffisance énergétique est
possible pour une centaine d'habitants
elle semble difficilement applicables à
l'échelle de tout un pays
ça me laisse qu'il s'agit réellement
d'une utopie bien oui et non parce que
ça existe ailleurs il faut savoir que
dans toute l'europe
en tout il ya trois îles qui ont atteint
l'autosuffisance en énergies
renouvelables
il ya bien sûr règles qu'on a vu dans le
reportage mais il y en a aussi une en
espagne et une autre au danemark où il
ya quand même quatre mille habitants
alors vous allez me dire 3 il s'est très
peu pour toute l'europe
mais il y a de plus en plus d'îles qui
prenne ce chemin par exemple aide fait
partie d'un archipel de quatre îles en
tout et les trois autres îles sont aussi
en train de créer leurs propres systèmes
d'énergies renouvelables la seule
différence c'est qu'elles ont dû le
faire sans subventions européennes sa
nièce qu'on pourrait généraliser
l'exemple de l'île des cas d'autres
territoires au royaume-uni wire alors on
pourrait peut-être un jour mais pour
l'instant ce serait très compliqué à
cause du stockage
ce qu'il faudrait énormément de
batteries pour stocker l'énergie de
plusieurs millions de consommateurs
qu'il faudrait aussi l'énergie pour
faire fonctionner des usines n'y en a
pas sur l'île de il y en a énormément en
france par exemple
donc en fait pour l'instant on se rend
compte que c'est un modèle qui est
possible mais qui est surtout adaptée à
des petites communautés isolées comme
meg qu'on a vu dans le reportage qui de
toute façon on n'avait pas réellement
d'autre choix
mais on voit en france qui a énormément
aussi de petits territoires de la sorte
ou alors même des îles pourquoi est ce
que on n'a pas plus d'exemples l'heure
on pourrait théoriquement mais en fait
en france c'est impossible il ya une île
qui a essayé de le faire elle se trouve
en bretagne
elle s'appelle l'île de sein et elle est
en contact avec lille dingue
ils ont voulu faire le même projet
simplement c'est un projet qui est
bloqué par edf et edf a la loi de son
côté parce qu'en france il y à une loi
qui dit que dans les territoires
insulaires
l'apport des énergies renouvelables ne
peut pas dépasser 30 % de la
consommation électrique
donc si on veut le faire un jour en
france et bien il faudra changer la loi
d'abord écouté message à nos gouvernants
merci ça va bien merci
voilà c'est fini merci à emmaüs défi
margot les salariés des compagnons de
cet atelier du 19e arrondissement nous
on se retrouve très vite sur public
sénat
et tous les jours sur publicsenat.fr
ciao
bon